cada uno de estos pedazos representa un
cuarto del área del pastel entonces por
aquí tenemos el pastel y está dividido
en uno dos tres cuatro pedazos entonces
tenemos cuatro pedazos y nos preguntan
si cada uno de estos cuatro pedazos
representan un cuarto del pastel bueno
primero pensemos en lo que significa
tener una fracción como un cuarto
un cuarto bueno el 1 es el numerador y
representa la cantidad de pedazos que
vamos a tomar así que en este caso vamos
a tomar un pedazo un pedazo o una parte
de y bueno ahora déjame hacer esta línea
por aquí porque vamos a hablar del
denominador que en este caso es 4 y el 4
lo que representa este denominador es en
cuántas secciones iguales estamos
dividiendo nuestro entero en cuántas
secciones iguales
estamos dividiendo algo entonces en este
caso tenemos secciones iguales y justo
la pregunta es
es cada pedazo de arriba uno de estos
cuatro pedazos iguales bueno vamos a ver
y creo que en este caso es bastante
claro
estos dos pedazos que tengo aquí este y
este de aquí no tienen el mismo tamaño
que los dos pedazos centrales que éste y
que este y de hecho si a ti te gustará
mucho el pastel de cereza como este que
tenemos aquí no vas a estar muy feliz si
te tocan uno de los pedazos que tenemos
a la orilla o de los pedazos finales y
esto porque este pastel no está dividido
en secciones iguales entonces este
pastel está dividido en cuatro pedazos
no en cuatro pedazos iguales y iguales
entonces cada uno de estos pedazos
representa un cuarto del área del pastel
bueno la respuesta es no no no no no no
cada pedazo no es un cuarto o un pedazo
igual de todo el pastel